Working for the SCP Foundation is no walk
in the park.
You’re forced to remain under a veil of
secrecy at all times, risking your life every
single day contending with dangerous and inexplicable
anomalies, and sometimes, you have to do things
that you’re not proud of.
Whether it’s forcing others to collect the
dangerous Y-909 compound from SCP-3000, the
giant eel responsible for creating the chemicals
in amnestics, or engaging in a variety of
innumerable unscrupulous activities all done
in service of maintaining normalcy, the nature
of work at the Foundation invites difficult
problems with no clear solutions.
Moral dilemmas challenging enough to give
a philosopher an aneurysm and enough trauma
that amnestics became standard issue tools
in a Foundation personnel’s arsenal.
Not just to wipe the minds of others, but
also to use on themselves, allowing their
mental states a reprieve from the atrocities
they may or may not have committed.
But that’s part of the job description.
You know what you’re signing up for when
it comes to the SCP Foundation, even if you’re
unsure of what your job will entail.
What you need to understand is that when you
work for the SCP Foundation, every day could
potentially be your last, and if it’s not
yours, it’s almost definitely someone else’s.
Maybe that’s what the recruiting officers
tell prospective researchers and agents to
really cheer them up!
Sometimes, carrying out the Foundation’s
morally questionable acts results in - or
in some cases - requires one of the most irreversible,
permanent actions: taking a life.
Death is a common sight at the Foundation.
Your job is constantly at risk of prematurely
disappearing due to one faulty containment
chamber leading to a full-scale breach, or
just having the bad luck that comes with being
one of the first ones to explore a mysterious
location before all of the anomalous effects
within are mapped out.
Being assigned to a dangerous anomaly will
practically ensure you’ll see death, and
potentially be the cause of it.
D-Class personnel are the Foundation’s lab
rats, reportedly sourced from death row inmates
and other unsavory characters; these guys
do the jobs that no one else wants to do.
Whether it’s cleaning the containment chamber
of a hostile, neck-snapping SCP-173, or venturing
into the dark, unending depths of SCP-087’s
staircases, there is no shortage of incredibly
dangerous tasks for the Foundation to hand
out.
With so much death and destruction surrounding
them, It shouldn’t come as a surprise that
the Foundation initiated Project Dammerung
to research what happens after death, if anything.
But that’s another story entirely, let’s
keep talking about D-Class personnel.
There’s always someone behind the D-Class,
the one giving orders.
And when those orders result in the loss of
life, it’s going to weigh down on that person’s
consciousness, death row inmate or not.
Sometimes amnestics are enough to smooth it
over, sometimes not.
But no one can say that the Foundation does
not have an insensitivity to death.
It only takes one look at an SCP file’s
cold, clinical delivery of a brutal experiment
gone wrong to realize this.
Names listed, names redacted, sometimes it
really feels like all these deaths are just
numbers and statistics for the Foundation
to report.
Maybe the “D” really does stand for disposable.
On one hand, it’s understandable.
The Foundation is an institution of science,
and the need for reports to be as accurate,
detailed, and professional as possible outweighs
the sorrow and sadness that comes with the
loss of life, but on the other hand, would
it hurt these guys to show some humanity for
once?
It’s always a crowd-pleaser when the Foundation
comes down from its high horse and goes the
extra mile to show how much they care.
Like when the legendary D-14134 single-handedly
saved the world from the deadly SCP-1983,
a barn house infested with vicious, heart-collecting
entities that even the Foundation had difficulty
dealing with.
Sure, D-14134 died, but he was posthumously
awarded the Foundation Star for his efforts!
The second ever D-Class to do so!
Okay, maybe the Foundation needs a bit of
work on figuring out how best to honor its
most respected members.
But is this cold, detached outlook just a
result of years of exposure to the hardships
of anomalous containment, or is there something
larger at play?
This SCP-001 proposal just may provide your
answer.
As we’ve explained before, there is no single
SCP-001, but many.
An old Foundation legend passed down between
personnel says that many of the highly-classified
001 files are fake, mere diversions to confuse
a true 001, a file so secretive that the Foundation
resorted to deception on a scale untold just
to hide it’s existence.
But that’s just a rumor.
The truth is that the 001 database is composed
of dozens of proposals, all of which detail
objects of high importance and standing to
the Foundation at large.
From Tufto’s Proposal, which details the
surprising history behind the threshold between
antiquity and modernity, the Scarlet King,
to Ball’s Proposal, which focuses around
a Sheaf of Papers with the capability to create
anomalies, these files don’t shy away from
covering big questions and delivering even
bigger answers.
But as always, keep in mind that due to the
inherent mystery and veil of secrecy involved
in an SCP-001 file, not everything may be
true, or appear as simple as it seems.
The anomaly we’ll be looking at today is
Solvex’s SCP-001 Proposal, which on the
onset, looks deceptively simple.
SCP-001 is an antique lamp, like one you’d
see at a pawn shop, or in your grandparent’s
attic.
While the material of the lamp itself is decidedly
not anomalous, the fuel space is filled with
class-A ectomorphs, an anomalous particle.
Foundation researchers have hypothesized that
the presence of these particles allow for
the lamp’s flames to burn indefinitely,
and an experiment testing these capabilities
lasted for over a month with no signs of extinction.
Viewing its flames triggers an anomalous effect,
the suppression of responsibility for deaths
caused by the viewer.
That’s right, SCP-001 extinguishes responsibility
for your actions, specifically those that
have resulted in the deaths of others.
While your conscience may be lightened, this
object acts only as a distraction, the memory
of the deaths still exist.
If mentioning such a death absolutely cannot
be avoided, viewers of SCP-001 will instead
describe it with a euphemism.
Ever wonder why the Foundation uses the terms
‘neutralized’ or ‘terminated’ so much?
That’s because SCP-001 is required viewing
for members of the Foundation.
Initially, following the item’s retrieval
in Texas, SCP-001 was cataloged as a simple
anomaly, a light that did not burn out.
It’s secondary effect of alleviating responsibility
was discovered after the fact, no doubt after
some researchers felt unusually calm about
sending a few individuals to their deaths
- sorry I meant “terminations” - in service
of the Foundation one day.
Its effects transfer even to pictures and
videos of SCP-001’s flames, which are distributed
to all Foundation personnel under a directive
referred to as the Acquittal Protocol.
Discovering SCP-001 was truly beneficial to
the early Foundation, whose personnel understandably
struggled with having to take lives and make
hard decisions.
Before the discovery of this object, those
working for organizations investigating the
anomalous had to live with untold atrocities
weighing down on them.
Take for example another SCP-001 proposal,
The Factory.
One of the many conflicting, varying origin
stories for the Foundation, the Factory was
one of the first anomalies investigated by
the Foundation, before it had even been established
as the Foundation.
A horrific industrial factory, filled to the
brim with tortured workers, burning machines,
and the stench of death.
While the Factory was dealt with to the best
of the early Foundation’s abilities, those
involved in the operation were scarred, and
rightfully so.
Perhaps to older generations of Foundation
employees who lived through horrors unimaginable,
exposing the entire organization to this SCP-001
Lamp was the right thing to do.
To spare the future generations of Foundation
workers from having to live with the consequences
of their actions.
But in doing so, in utilizing an anomaly on
such a large group of people against their
will, what is the Foundation robbing from
the people who work for it?
As Overseer O5-1 once described it in a correspondence
letter regarding SCP-001, “I still regret
that people who join us to protect mankind
from abnormalities are changed into abnormalities
and contained as such.
But still we must keep going until we find
a better way than this method.
We must always do our best.”
In a way, the transformation of the very morality
of a human being is an anomaly in itself.
By negating the effects of witnessing death,
you deliberately create behavior that goes
against hundreds of thousands of years of
biological wiring.
Those exposed to SCP-001 are changed fundamentally.
Metaphorically, this is the curse of the Foundation
researcher.
Sworn to protect, sworn to die in the dark
in silence, so that others may live in the
light.
And like all vows of secrecy, it comes with
a cost.
It shouldn’t come as a surprise that a large
number of Foundation personnel work with the
organization as a generational calling.
Take the Bright family for instance.
Once you’re in, there’s no getting out,
and it’s a lot easier to live as a family
with knowledge of the Foundation than someone’s
parent attempting to balance a double life
as a senior researcher.
For some members of the Foundation, they were
thrown into this life before they were even
born, and anomalies like SCP-001 only cement
the line that divides an ordinary person from
those working behind the Veil.
The Foundation secures, contains, and protects,
but the people making up the massive organization
are just that - people.
By furthering the divide between the general
public and a member of the SCP Foundation,
you only ensure what O5-1 already knew.
He continued:
“Organizations that protect mankind from
anomalous objects have existed all over the
world for a long time.
Although there have been numerous ways of
protection, it is indispensable to gain knowledge
of anomalies, and the processes inevitably
include experiments using living human beings.
This varies depending on times and regions
such as criminals, slaves, different ethnic
groups and so on.
Nevertheless, it still largely eroded the
minds of the researchers.
Some people could not bear their sins and
threw themselves into the sea.
Another person eliminated the distinction
between life and death to keep his peace of
mind, but then he killed his family due to
a slight quarrel.
I told many personnel repeatedly that these
sacrifices lead to protecting the world.
Such words are, however, only so effective,
and many personnel’s hearts were understandably
broken.”
But I found that lamp.
The circumstances were coincidental, but its
effect is noteworthy.
Researchers have been able to study gruesome
anomalies without so much a care in the world.
As a result, their work efficiency dramatically
increased, and the damage caused by the abnormities
was soon negligible.
Of course, the feelings remained, but there
were measures in place now.
Amnestics, advanced anomalous therapies.
If we wanted, we could remove the very emotion
of sadness from a man’s psyche.
But we couldn’t.
We’re already too far gone, and the lasting
effects of this lamp weigh on my mind the
way it is.
Those who abandoned their responsibility for
death by themselves became heterogeneous in
daily life where general morality exists.
They had become impossible to live among the
general public.”
Institutions such as the Ethics Committee,
the board of directors responsible for maintaining
the Foundation’s moral integrity, can only
do so much when surrounded by the amount of
death the average secure facility deals with.
This is likely why directives such as the
Acquittal protocol are greenlit.
It doesn’t entirely negate the effects of
death, but it works pretty well as a cheap,
simple, organization-wide amnestic, pushing
the uncomfortable memories and thoughts to
the back of the mind until they’re absolutely
needed, and even then making sure to sugarcoat
them in the most detached, robotic way possible.
So, the next time you think you want to submit
a job application to the SCP Foundation, think
of SCP-001, as well as all the other difficult,
immoral tasks you may be asked to perform.
Is throwing away your humanity in service
of the goal of containment a noble one?
What about changing the impact of one of life’s
most constant elements - death?
Whatever the answer may be, there’s one
thing everyone can agree on - the life of
Foundation personnel is not for everyone,
and it certainly isn’t easy on the mind.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The Way The
World Ends - Reality Unfolds” and “SCP-001
- Which is the Real 001?
(SCP Animation)” for more wicked and wild
SCP–001 possibilities!